the question for the two of you but
first I have to ask Mike do you hate the
Red Sox no not at all
Boston's just never been messed up and a
big screen movie before so I thought it
was time manty of San Francisco in New
York again boring no real question for
the two of you I would imagine making
this film was an amazing experience
could each of you share like a day or
two that you'll always remember from
making the film oh that's a good one
so many days have gone by it's hard to
pick it's been over a three-year
adventure for me personally I can tell
you about a prank I pulled I i pranks
are healthy because they keep everybody
on their toes and you know making a
movie can be very very stressful and so
there was one night we were shooting
particularly late and I think everybody
had had it especially with me it was a
full cast it was the scene where Veera
is calling into the jet and then
explaining why she did what she did and
it's a very long scene and very
emotional and there was a lot of Ken and
the other actors you know staring at her
on this monitor we're doing take out
there take so tired I know I'm sorry
and and we thought we had it and I said
no no I need one more
and so rolled cameras and they're going
through it and then just at a key moment
in the scene instead of playing the
footage of the devastation that Veera
had was trying to explain we queued up a
very key scene from one of Ken's classic
movies which I most vacation last scene
and love scene with Chanti
so is the key moment in Memoirs of a
Geisha when Ken and Zhi lock lips and
that had a nice stress-relieving
and everyone to cheering that was a good
one but they were just holding it I did
it there's all slow at pranks I used to
put severed limbs and rubber snakes and
the water coolers for the crew
I left a life-sized Regan MacNeil from
The Exorcist and Millie's trailer who
then proceeded to put it in Vera's
trailer so it was just a good way to
keep the stress levels down hey Paul
sorry from google.com this question is
more to a Jew like there's a lot of
monsters in this movie what let in to
the choices to go with the ones that you
guys went with I'm very curious how you
chose who you're gonna chip how you were
gonna we're gonna focus on throughout
the film
you mean like Mothra Rodin yeah yeah
yeah I mean there they are the there I
keep saying it but they're the crown
jewels of the Toho universe they're the
ones that I feel like most Godzilla fans
and Nan even non Godzilla fans are the
most familiar with so as much as I love
King Caesar and Gigan and those guys
they're a little bit more obscure but
they're also the first ones who kind of
teamed up you know there's there's a key
point in Godzilla history when Mothra
Rodin and Godzilla put aside their
differences and decided to team up
against King Ghidorah it's an amazing
scene by the way I strongly suggest you
go back and watch that movie but there's
a there's literally a scene where larval
Mothra goes to Mothra or goes to Rodin
and Godzilla and says hey this new poll
just showed up and he's gonna mess
everything up if we don't stop him and
the two twin fairies are translating for
the monsters but so the humans can
understand what the monsters are talking
about like they're actually having
dialogue with each other and Rodin and
Godzilla are like the humans they bully
us like why should we help them and
suddenly was for the first time as a kid
that was where you suddenly saw things
in the monsters point of view where the
monster saw us as the monster
the monsters saw us as the bullies that
were trying to prevent them from having
happy lives but anyways I think you
sense the they were sort of the first
giant monster team-up and I feel like
they're truly the most iconic of the
Touhou universe so it made sense that
they should be the first ones to get
readapted to the big big screen for
Hollywood
excuse me might go monsters they're
characters
I used the M word hey I'm Josh from
Singapore I Vic the grief of a mother
can awaken the great monsters of the
world right yes my question is on the
pacing of the film I thought it was
exhilarating how did you find like a
board of faders how did you find the
sweet spot for the tension building the
action the horror the spectacle and also
a social commentary it's hard I mean the
movie really is created in the editing
room and there's a lot of material that
ended up on the cutting room floor
there's a there's a cut that I like to
call it Godzilla the miniseries because
it was basically three hours so there
were much longer versions of the scenes
that you saw and as much as I would love
just bathe in the Godzilla universe for
three hours it it dragged so we had to
find that right sweet spot as you put it
and it took a very very long time this
is not hi I'm Daniella from Australia
from the east come to you I've got two
questions inside okay first of all I
found it really interesting that there
were women like you know normally in a
movie when there's military it's an old
white guy so I'm really interested in
what was your thinking having kind of
such cool kick-ass women and women of
color in those sorts of roles I mean
honestly if you go back and look at the
history of Godzilla films women who
kick-ass have been a strong part of it
from the very very beginning I mean you
can go back to the original but I mean
the Mothra fairies and the old movies
are very key characters and as a kid
that made an impression
but I love those kinds of characters I
mean Ripley and Sarah Connor I mean
they're icons as far as I'm concerned so
I'm glad the rest of the world is
catching up but I feel like there's just
a long history of kick-ass women in
sci-fi and horror especially so yeah I
just feel like the rest of the world is
just now starting to kind of catch on
under the idea that that's an okay thing
to have in mainstream movies just one
more quick one um what do you want the
or do you want the audience to take
something away from this about our
relationship with the natural world
right now we're trying to instill that
sort of take away or no no again that
that's that's been a message of the
gazella films from the very beginning in
1954 and I think that the message is
really whatever you want to make of it
but it's it's it's there I don't think
it's that confusing it's it's don't up
the planet otherwise mother mother
nature releases her 800 Megaton monsters
for me personally this film really is
about finding a symbiotic relationship
between man and Godzilla slash nature
like to meet Godzilla always has been
Mother Nature's protector he's been you
know like I said 800 800 Megaton
gorillas and he's here to protect the
planet against any monster whether they
be 400 feet tall or human beings so yeah
it's there it's always been there if you
make a Godzilla film without that
message is not a Godzilla film it's just
a giant monster movie why in the US
America in the u.s. Godzilla the
interaction with the human level
indicator level is so high um I don't
know I don't know if that's completely
true Robby I feel like I hate to keep
saying but if you go back and look at
the home history of Godzilla films
there's they interact with him a lot and
maybe personally I was more affected by
those moments because I think that's
what the message of
all the movies are trying to say is it
is about that interaction it is about
that relationship that there is a
possible connection to be made between
giant monsters and human beings that no
living organism lives on its own it's
all about that delicate relationship
between different species okay and what
you lose you power it good Zeeland
beside yours the original yeah thank you
I David Crowe with the den of geek and I
wanted I was curious to kind of continue
on the last several questions the
process of deciding how much to
modernize or Americanize the mythology a
little bit like you've mentioned the
fairies and it's alluded to is it who
called that raise your hand if you
caught the the twin fairies well I
related to that so how much do you
debate how much to believe in of that
same with King Ghidorah hinted at being
an alien in this it's it's it's a
process I feel like because you're
making a film that has such a deep fan
base you have to have enough of those
kinds of hints and nods to keep fans
happy but you can't focus on it too much
that distracts for the general audience
either so I love Easter eggs I like to
reward people for paying attention so my
personal favorite films are the ones
where I notice things I never noticed
before you know a lot of the classics
details that the directors snuck in
there that only revealed themselves
sometimes on home video you know like to
this day I still notice things in alien
or Blade Runner that I haven't noticed
and then decades that I've been watching
them on repeat so I just think it's fun
it's fun hi I'm Jeff with cinema blend
so this cast is ridiculous
just super amazing like newcomers to the
franchise it's not even the main three
but like you know Bradley Whitford
O'Shea Jackson jr. you know Charles
dance the list goes on like how did you
establish such an impressive ensemble
and for Ken is it refreshing to work
with new faces such talented people in
the new moons bowling you go first
are we enjoying and uh you know John C
is his most friend family made my
character and the Sally Hawkins I love
her and then uh izakaya and any other
cast it's so powerful
and then honorable yeah and yeah it just
came to get everybody said yes it's
right down the list everybody said yes
and what was fun for me was sort of
preaching the word of Godzilla to the
newcomers because there were a lot of
people Millie obviously who weren't that
familiar I mean I feel like everyone has
heard of Godzilla or they've caught one
on cable you know in reruns and things
like that but it was fun to sit down and
really kind of explain Godzilla to them
and for someone like Milly we bonded
over the fact that we both love animals
and nature and so I explained to her
that while Godzilla's not just about
giant rubber monsters beating the crap
out of each other there's actually this
very wonderful message about the
importance of nature and animals and our
connection to them so she really sparked
it and it's really why she signed up and
the other folks as well like Bradley
Whitford like he that that message
really resonated with him so I think it
was it was fun for them to be part of
something so big and fun and
entertaining but also knowing that it
had some social awareness underneath it
it's like a delicious dessert that's
actually good for you I am at least I'm
from Paris and I have a question for Ken
I would like to know what is you very
first memory about GU Zia as a Japanese
kid
I didn't see the original just before I
was born and then I just I love that
Mothra yeah and then to tweens songs and
dancing and yeah it's very beautiful and
then but I didn't I don't like the you
know
Gojira more than Camila just blasphemy
and that secret oh yeah camera is not
Toho just so in case there's any
confusion yeah hi great movie phone mr.
Watanabe I was wondering I was so
transfixed by everything that you were
doing the minute that you were hugging
everyone goodbye and getting in the ship
and then approaching Godzilla could you
explain what you were actually seeing
were you on a set what was green screen
because it all felt very real to me when
I was looking at your face ah it's huge
said just kidding and yeah it's just
really complex answer and I would like
to say in Japanese sounds like Gojira
and there are I was a senior sir do you
know our son Okamoto captain watched in
a while Gino kappamini
Carragher Kaku it's got a Kaku the
Hibakusha yo in do not forget to it
works the Sun cocoon yolk TV samsa Rita
Gojira Oh muchos de negocio y hasta
meneka Cusco do SEO Nico EW no naka de
musica musica mo conde navara demo site
so technically condo semiotics ni so you
y una momento
ha I said that dirty monster so that
scene was a very complicated scene for
me we used to I used to my pocket watch
which was a great significance because
the pocket watch was something that was
in the possession of Sarah Zoe's father
from the Japanese war when when they
dropped the nuclear bomb and it's
significant because Godzilla was born
from nuclear but now Serizawa is using
newly nuclear to revive him and and it
was a very complicated feeling for
Serizawa and to revive calls that are
using nuclear and and also keeping in
mind that that Godzilla has needed to
ultimately needed to to restore balance
and help humankind by the way while
shooting that scene the moment that
Serizawa climbed the steps and reached
the top and got to Godzilla I saw
something happen I've never seen and any
other feeling films I've directed and
I've never heard of that happening on
set before but he did the scene and the
entire crew broke into applause at the
end which was just surreal because it's
obviously it's not heavy dialogue by any
means but I think they were captivated
by his just expression and his
performance even though so much of it
was unspoken in my memory yes it's in
the wall that's first touch to the cozy
life yeah I think there was one previous
film where a person climbed onto
Godzilla and tried to shoot him with a
handgun I don't know what they were
thinking but I think this is the first
time in Godzilla's history or he's been
touched affectionately which is deep
meaning for me personally I mean Sarah's
always characters the one I
with the most so having his character be
the one that actually makes contact with
Godzilla meant a lot to me to see that
like atom touching the head of God
hi I'm Jerome from collectors Mike I
wanted to know why was it so special for
you to work on a doll movie
and second is Godzilla king of the
monsters paving the way to go see across
the universe
what kind of I'm sorry like the cross
universe move Eli quickly cut Saddam and
come on it's way
oh I see yes you know mm-hmm together
crust universe um I mean it meant a lot
to me because I think I mentioned
earlier in the introduction was that I
grew up watching these movies when I was
a kid you know a four years old five
years old I was a little half asian kid
growing up in Ohio and I was made fun of
a lot and to watch these amazing movies
about giant monsters and I already had a
love of dinosaurs and animals in nature
that were made by other Asian people
meant the world to me you know because
other than that it was cowboys and cops
and robbers and just your typical TV
shows and movies growing up and Godzilla
sort of provided this weird security
blanket because he was so strong he was
so powerful but besides the fact that it
was entertaining and fun I was keenly
aware even at that young age that there
was a message underneath all of it and I
heard that and that meant a lot you know
in the same way that Star Wars is really
a movie about spirituality
if you dissect it Godzilla had this like
oddly subversive message to it so that
resonated and the fact that it was made
by other Asian people just meant a lot
and so I wanted to continue that my
first attempt
making a film I think I was around 10
years old was I took my family's Betamax
camcorder yes I'm not old and set it up
and I took my pet tortoise which does
box tortoise named Tony and let her
rampage through my Star Wars figures and
that was my first instinct was to make a
Godzilla movie and then I attend I try
to do it again in college I made a
two-minute Godzilla film and so it's
just always been in the back of my head
that I wanted to do that and I'll even
remember when I was in college they were
shooting Roland Emmerich's movie in New
York and I was like a little bit jealous
a little bit angry that I wasn't gonna
be able to do it but here we are as far
as whether this film is setting up a
larger universe I mean we don't drop
Kong's name for nothing
but I mean honestly Toho has been doing
this since the 50s and 60s you know God
bless Marvel for what they've done and
sort of reviving and modernizing the
concept of cinematic universes they
deserve all the accolades in the world
for it
but you know the first attempts at it
were the monster verse the monster
universe that Universal was just quietly
attempting to build back in the 30s and
40s
but then Toho really took the ball and
ran with it and it's because they
crossed over a Mothra Rodin and Godzilla
that that concept really grew and so I
feel like the legendary monster verse
working with Toho is really bringing it
back home with growing up agent good
love film Seven Samurai and Godzilla
were highly impactful like in my life so
usually - yeah Bruce Lee I mean it was
so cool saying all that but my question
was of a pretty big Godzilla fan and I
did a quick search of Atlantis Godzilla
did you pull from Godzilla the Colossus
of Atlantis in episode 4 1978 or was
that sort of a natural inspiration it
wasn't a direct pool or inspiration no I
I've always loved Jules Verne style
adventures I feel like movies don't have
enough of that anymore and I personally
love theories about lost civilizations
and growing up I'll never forget the
disappointment I felt when I found out
that mankind and dinosaur did not live
together you know that decades of like
Ray Harryhausen movies lied to me and
this seemed like a natural fit I mean
personally I loved the concept that
there was a previous civilization that
figured out how to live with the kaiju
that cracked that code and figured out
how to form a symbiotic relationship for
their own survival and that some
Cataclysm broke that relationship and so
while human beings sort of went off and
forgot about their connection to the
monsters and chopped up the monsters to
fairy tales and legends Godzilla never
forgot you know which is why he has some
weird distant memory of these tiny
little squeaky creatures and maybe there
is some sort of affection there which is
why Serizawa says like we would be we
would be his pets because maybe that's
how he views us first I think that I
agree with you just just so you know I
truly believe that you add Godzilla to
any movie it becomes a better movie
right think about it take any movie in
the world and 20 minutes in Godzilla
shows up guarantee you it's more
entertaining my question is for Ken and
also for Michael um talk to me about the
opportunities and maybe some of the
difficulties about making this a strong
individual movie that stands on its own
but also being part of a the larger
incredible history of Godzilla and also
the monster verse that we're talking
about that's currently underway
as an actor just doesn't neither big
gods small just focus on the character
and make it a character with a director
and a cast or something and then I mean
then as a filmmaker and a fan it's
challenging but I'm challenging it's my
job but at the same time like there are
entries and we're you know we're now
part of a generation which has been
subjected to decades of these franchise
films I'm sure many of you are fans of
Star Trek and Star Wars and alien and
you know all of that or nightmare down
the street you name it so there's a long
history of franchise films many of which
have very strong chapters and weaker
chapters and as a fan of those kinds of
films I like to focus on the stronger
chapters and like what is it that makes
them great why do they stand out and
typically what I find are the ones that
do stand out are the ones sort of that
they stand on their own you can enjoy
them whether you're a fan of that
particular franchise or not I'll never
forget seeing aliens for the first time
and my aunt who had never seen the first
movie walked out and she was still blown
away by it
you know Star Trek 2 very similar so
it's a tricky balancing act similar to
the previous questions where you have to
be able to provide enough entertainment
for the traditional fan base that loves
it but also you have to be welcoming
enough to new audience members that
they'll also understand it and enjoy it
and hopefully you're communicating the
deep love that you have to that general
audience I need to say about that one
more thing and then you know I have to
fight it so many good you know found
fans
and it's a tough fight you know so many
knowledge and the history hi Michael I'm
Daniel from rocket beans Germany and I
have a question for you and if you do or
if you could direct another Godzilla
movie which kaiju should be definitely
in it which is the favorite one you
couldn't directly get now uh so like
which monster from the Toho Hansy on uh
there's one creature that I find
fascinating because she's a plant
her name's biollante and and she's also
one of the very few other female kaiju
but she she's interesting because she's
almost like this Frankenstein creature
she's a combination of DNA from a
scientists dead daughter Godzilla and
arose and it's like Audrey on steroids
but it's it there's something just so
interest because I find that she's also
very misunderstood but she and she also
gave Godzilla a run for his money okay
this will be our last question
hello hi my name is Brandon from
Malaysia just two quick questions number
one of you know tolls there is such a
rich history with Godzilla and all the
abundance of off of creatures and one
citizens for Michael for you to come in
were there any creative differences in
when you guys are planning a story and
with a you know disagreements and how do
you guys overcome this creative
differences with Toho Studios and for
Ken I asked this question to Michael oh
yeah what do you think is Godzilla's
favorite sashimi
[Laughter]
you know personally I don't think gunsel
eats fish I think we they made that
mistake before
as far as creative conflicts or
differences there weren't really many at
all we were really in sync with each
other I mean the the most intimidating
moment for me personally was coming here
at Tokyo and Towe had final approval on
all the designs for the creatures and so
I had spent a few months coming up with
the designs with my creature guys and
presented to them and I love the Toho
guys right but when you walk it's a
little intimidating as everyone's
wearing a suit you know it's a long long
conference room table and I'd show them
everything and thankfully signed off on
it